[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und marietaslomka guten Abend sein
Angebot eines deutschlandpaktes richtete
Olaf Scholz bei der Generaldebatte heute
im Bundestag zwar auch an CDU-Chef
Friedrich Merz vor allem aber an die
Ministerpräsidenten von cdu/csu ohne die
Bundesländer werden sich viele
ampelpläne schwerlich umsetzen lassen
bei den Finanzen reden sie eh mit aber
auch Bürokratieabbau lässt sich ja nicht
einfach von Berlin aus befehlen
das nun ausgerechnet Hendrik wüst
Ministerpräsident des großen
Nordrhein-Westfalen und einen
CDU-Politiker der eher konziliant
auftritt und kooperativ mit den Grünen
regiert das also wüst sagt er fühle sich
von Scholz veräppelt weil es solche
Initiativen längst gäbe aber die Ampel
nicht zu Potter komme dann ist das kein
gutes Zeichen für den Bundeskanzler die
Debatte in Berlin hat Daniel Potzel
verfolgt
bevor diese eine seine neue Vokabel zum
ersten Mal fällt hat der
Oppositionsführer das Wort dessen Kritik
fundamental die zeitenwände sei zur
übergangsfinanzierung der Bundeswehr
geschrumpft die Klimapolitik der Ampel
ineffektiv dringend nötige
Grenzkontrollen würden verweigert und
arbeiten lohne sich nicht mehr
die Menschen die zu faul sind die
Menschen können einfach rechnen im
Gegensatz zu manchen von ihnen vier Tage
Woche früh Verrentung Bürgergeld meine
Damen und Herren das Problem sind nicht
die Menschen die das in Anspruch nehmen
die ist das Problem sind sie die das
ermöglichen der Kanzler wie sämtliche
Vorwürfe zurück verwies auf das
Geleistete und gebar dann dieses neue
Wort das eine gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung von Bund Ländern und
Kommunen beschreiben soll viele im Lande
warten gerade zu sehensüchtig nach einem
solchen Schulterschluss und ich möchte
ihn deshalb ein Pakt vorschlagen sagen
wir einen deutschland-pakt ein
Deutschland packt der unser Land
schneller moderner und sicherer macht
Tempo statt Stillstand handeln statt
aussetzen
Kooperation statt Streiterei die Union
antwortet später man sei durchaus bereit
für einen solchen packt im Prinzip halt
aber fest
Sie uns ein Angebot zur Zusammenarbeit
machen weil sie in ihrer eigenen Ampel
für zentrale Fragen keine Mehrheit mehr
sehen der Bundeskanzler soweit so
gewöhnlich dass die Opposition sich eine
andere Regierung wünscht ist üblich dass
die Regierungsfraktion sich eine sehr
konkret andere Opposition wünschen eher
nicht wir
brauchen genauso wie das bayerische
Bierzelt wir brauchen eine konservative
Partei die sagen kann der Christ
opher ist Deutschland genauso wie die
Bayreuther Festspiele und wir brauchen
eine konservative Partei die sagen kann
der Islam gehört zu Deutschland genauso
wie der Evangelische Kirchentag eine
stattliche Spannbreite wie sie auch die
Koalition selbst aufweist woran wenig
später der fDP-Fraktionschef erinnert
als er sich wie Scholz gegen Robert
habecks Idee eines industriestrompreises
wendet ich glaube nicht dass
Senkung sprechen wir könnten Sie auf das
europäische Minimum reduzieren AFD und
Linke bemühen bei ihrer Generalkritik
jeweils historische Vergleiche und
warnen damit wohl am meisten vor dem
jeweils anderen
es gab schon einmal einen Kanzler der
Deutschland mit seiner Sparpolitik
ruiniert hat Heinrich brüdig
Reichskanzler der Weimarer Republik von
1930 bis 1932 und wohin das geführt hat
und welche politischen Kräfte dadurch
stark geworden sind das wissen wir Ihre
Wahrnehmung ist mittlerweile vollkommen
abgekoppelt von der Lebenswirklichkeit
sie leben in einer Scheinwelt das hat
Züge von den letzten Tagen der
Volkskammer in der DDR die Idee des
deutschland-pakts stieß bei ihnen
erwartungsgemäß auf wenig Resonanz bei
einem anderen dafür auf erwartungsgemäß
viel der Bundes
Wehr meine Fraktion sagen dass wir an
diesem deutschland- werden es war eine
oft leidenschaftliche geistige Debatte
womöglich aber nur die zwei täglichste
dieser Woche übermorgen soll ein selber
Stelle das sogenannte heizungsgesetz
verabschiedet werden
heute schon Update gibt es dazu doch ein
Interview mit dem CDU Abgeordneten Helge
braun ist Vorsitzender des
Haushaltsausschusses des Deutschen
Bundestags aber man kann ihn natürlich
auch noch als ehemaligen Chef des
Bundeskanzleramts unter Merkel
global betrachtet war dieser Sommer so
heiß wie noch nie jedenfalls seit Beginn
der Wetteraufzeichnung das geht aus
Daten des europäischen
erdbeobachtungsprogramms Kopernikus
hervor das heute seine Aufzeichnungen
für Juni bis August veröffentlichte
der Klimawandel habe zu extrem hohen
Meerestemperaturen geführt mit
entsprechenden Folgen einschließlich
extremen wetterumschwimmen in vielen
Regionen war es trockener oder nasser
als sonst im Durchschnitt üblich
Beispiel Griechenland da war es erst
extrem trocken und jetzt gibt es extrem
Starkregen der besonders betroffenen
Region in Mittelgriechenland stürzen
Wassermassen vom Himmel die die
Niederschlagsmenge seinerzeit im Ahrtal
um ein Vielfaches überstalten
es fließt und strömt durch die Straßen
das Wasser reißt alles mit was ich nicht
festhalten kann
Joana ist Landwirtin mitten in der Nacht
wird sie plötzlich von Fluten überrascht
ihren Hof völlig verwüstet zurücklassen
das Wasser abgelaufen ist da sehen sie
da lag alles verstreut herum in den
Fässern sind 200 kg Weizen und das
Wasser hat sie einfach mitgerissen was
soll ich noch sagen besonders hart
getroffen ist die Hafenstadt wolhus
wenige Kilometer nordöstlich wurden am
Dienstag Niederschlagsmengen von mehr
als 750 Litern pro Quadratmeter gemessen
mehr als jemals zuvor an einem Tag und
mehr als im gesamten vergangenen Jahr in
Deutschland durchschnittlich noch vor
wenigen Wochen bedrohten starke
Waldbrände wollers nun stehen die
Straßen unter Wasser
von wollers brennt sind wir zu Volos
ertrinkt übergegangen nur dass ihr
Menschen ertrinken und Eigentum verloren
geht
bislang wurden in Griechenland drei Tote
gemeldet viele Orts ist der Strom
ausgefallen Mobilfunknetze und
Internetversorgung zusammengebrochen
ganze Straßenabschnitte sind einfach
weggespült wir sind heute erst aus dem
Haus gegangen weil das Wasser rauschte
Sturzbäche wir haben kein Wasser wir
haben keinen Strom wir haben kein
Telefon es gibt nichts
doch das Sturmtief trifft nicht nur
Griechenland besonders betroffen sind
auch Bulgarien und die Türkei
Regenmassen spülen Fahrzeuge durch die
Straßen von Istanbul hinterlassen
Schlamm und eine Spur der Verwüstung
in Bulgarien zerstörte Straßen und
Brücken Häuser Ortschaften
im Stall auf Joanas Hof sind Küken
ertrunken ein totes Schaf wurde
angeschwemmt wohl von einem benachbarten
Landwirt dessen Angestellter noch
vermisst wird
ich warte jetzt darauf dass der Regen
aufhört damit wir Bilanz ziehen können
was passiert ist und was Hilfe betrifft
da können wir eine Kerze drauf anzünden
falls und wenn Hilfe kommt wird sie
verschwindend gering sein die gesamte
Gemeinde hat großen Schaden genommen wir
werden alleine zurechtkommen müssen
der Schaden ist die Mensch doch die Lage
könnte sich weiter zuspitzen heute Nacht
soll es in Griechenland weitere Stürme
weiteren Regen geben
als Reporterin für uns im griechischen
Unwettergebiet bei Larissa Annette wie
ist bei dir die Lage jetzt am Abend
ja seit einer halben Stunde regnet es
hier schüttet das hier und dazu
begleitet von donnerblitzen und heftigen
Winden also das hat hier wieder enorm
Fahrt aufgenommen
nachdem es am Nachmittag erstmal ein
bisschen ruhig geworden ist entsprechend
hatte der Katastrophenschutz bereits
eine Warnung rausgegeben bereits am
frühen Nachmittag wo es hieß es eben
dass man aufgrund der Wetterbedingungen
möglichst zu Hause bleiben soll für den
Bereich wollers also die Hafenstadt die
ja besonders stark betroffen ist da gibt
es sogar wieder eine Ausgangssperre und
wir sehen hinter mir wie schnell das
dann geht wie schnell dann so eine
Straße dann auch wieder überschwemmt ist
und völlig unpassierbar ist allerdings
werden denn eigentlich angesichts dieser
Situation auch Ortschaften evakuiert
also es gibt Evakuierungen von einzelnen
Dörfern oder von einzelnen Personen so
weit die zugänglich sind auch hier haben
wir gerade erlebt dass ein Mann der dort
versucht hat in seiner Plätzchenbäckerei
auszuharren der seine Angestellten
weggeschickt hatte aber selber ausharren
wollte letztendlich doch aufgegeben hat
die Polizei gerufen die Feuerwehr
gerufen hat und gerade eben gerettet
also evaku also aus dem Haus evakuiert
wurde
es gibt aber natürlich auch um Wollust
drumherum in den Gebirge inzwischen
Dörfer die sind von der Welt
abgeschnitten also da sind die Straßen
unpassierbar da kommen auch Retter nicht
in die werden Aushärten müssen bis der
Regen vorbei ist und die Hilfskräfte
sich dann wegfahren danke schön nette
für diese Informationen direkt aus den
unwettergebieten
und jetzt macht Gundula weiter mit
Nachrichten die beginnen in der Ukraine
bei einem russischen Angriff auf eine
Stadt im ostukrainischen Don was sind
mindestens 17 Menschen getötet worden
weitere 30 wurden verletzt als am
hellichten Tag Artillerie im
Stadtzentrum Einflug Russland betont
immer wieder nur militärische Ziele
anzugreifen getroffen wurden ein
Marktplatz und eine beliebte Straße
zugleich ist US-Außenminister blinken zu
einem unangekündigten Besuch in Kiew
dabei sagte er der Ukraine weitere
Militär Unterstützung zu
erstmals seit fünf Jahren halten sich
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder zu
Beratungen mit der EU-Kommission in
Brüssel auf zuvor hatte Niedersachsens
Regierungschef weil eindringlich für
einen staatlich subventionierten
industriestrompreis geworben die
Vereinbarkeit mit europäischem Recht
wird eines der Themen der morgigen
Beratungen in Brüssel sein
auch Brasilien leidet unter Extremwetter
ein heftiger Wirbelsturm hat im Süden
des Landes massive Überschwemmungen nahe
Flüssen und in vielen Städten verursacht
die Zahl der Todesopfer dort ist auf
mindestens 31 gestiegen damit kamen in
der Region so viele Menschen ums Leben
wie nie zuvor bei einem Wetter Ereignis
so der Gouverneur von Rio Grando das
soll
wegen des Angriffs auf das us-kapitol im
Januar 2021 soll der frühere Anführer
der rechtsradikalen Gruppe proud Boys
nun 22 Jahre in Haft Enrique Terrier war
an besagte am 6 Januar zwar nicht selbst
in Washington er sei aber der
Rädelsführer gewesen und habe den
Angriff seiner Mitstreiter angeleitet so
die Staatsanwaltschaft es ist die
bislang höchste Strafe in der
Aufarbeitung des Kapitol Sturms
der erste afrikanische Klimagipfel hat
sich auf gemeinsame Positionen für
internationale Klimaverhandlungen
verständigt dazu zählt die Forderung
nach einer globalen Steuer um
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen zu finanzieren
Voraussetzung sei so Kenias Präsident
Ruto ein fairer Umbau des weltweiten
Finanzsystems ein Erfolg des Gipfels
sein internationale investitionszusage
in Höhe von 23 Milliarden Euro für
erneuerbare Energien in Afrika ein
wichtiger Schritt für die
Weltklimakonferenz Ende November falls
dieser erste rein afrikanischer
Klimagipfel mit über 50 Teilnehmern ist
auch Zahl einer weltpolitischen
Entwicklung in der sich der sogenannte
globale Süden unabhängiger aufstellen
will mit eigenen Institutionen jenseits
der etablierten Formate die als vom
Westen dominiert gesehen werden China
treibt diese Prozesse voran gerade erst
ja mit der Erweiterung der brix-staaten
man sucht Verbündete im Konkurrenzkampf
mit den USA an diesem Wochenende beim
G20-Gipfel in Indien hätten dann aber
theoretisch alle Aufeinandertreffen
können die westlichen Industriestaaten
und der globale Süden die USA und China
selbst Russland gehört noch zu den G20
aber ein solches alle dabei wie in
früheren Zeiten wird es nicht geben und
das liegt nicht nur daran dass Vladimir
Putin lieber zu Hause bleibt und voller
Bericht
in Indiens Hauptstadt trainieren Sie
bereits um den G20-Gipfel zu schützen
aber die größte Gefahr droht von den
Makaken die die Straßen um den
Tagungsort des Gipfels fest im Griff
haben und gerne Besucher attackieren sie
sollen von scheinriesen Affen vertrieben
werden bei den Affen ist es wie bei den
Menschen die Illusion von macht ist
wichtig auch der willkommensfilm der
indischen Regierung propagiert eine
Illusion die von einer Welt die nach
Frieden strebt wir sind eine Familie
sagt Indiens Regierungschef weil
irgendwann family
zwei werden aber nicht kommen der
russische Präsident Putin wird per
internationalem Haftbefehl gesucht und
der chinesische Präsident Chi schickt
seinen Premierminister er will sich wohl
nicht die Aufmerksamkeit mit den
Amerikanern
china möchte ganz offensichtlich nicht
nach der amerikanischen Pfeife tanzen
sondern möchte Regeln haben die den
chinesischen Interessen eher
entsprechend der Ukraine Krieg ist ein
Angriff auf die regelbasierte
Weltordnung aber mit Schrecken mussten
die USA und Europa feststellen dass
viele Länder in Afrika und Asien das
nicht so interessiert
der Angriffskrieg verstößt gegen unsere
Moral und empört uns aber andere Länder
empört er nicht im Gegenteil sie treffen
sich mit dem russischen Außenminister um
Geschäfte zu machen
gemeint ist das Bündnis der brix-staaten
Brasilien Russland Indien China und
Südafrika so unterschiedlich ihre
Interessen sind ein sie der Vorbehalt
und auch natürlich die im Grunde die
nicht Akzeptanz dieses westlichen
Führungsanspruch
mit Hilfe der brix-staaten will China
die neue Weltordnung anführen es geht
dabei weniger um Moral als um Marktmacht
die G7 Staaten die lange die Weltbühne
dominierten verlieren an Einfluss wie
ein Vergleich der Entwicklung des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes also die
Wirtschaftskraft von G7 Staaten mit den
brix-staaten zeigt diese holen seit
Jahrzehnten auf und haben nun die G7
Staaten sogar überholt die chinesische
Sicht auf die westlichen Demokratie und
Marktwirtschaft ist schon die dass
beides in der Krise ist also sowohl die
politischen Systeme als auch die
wirtschaftlichen Systeme sind nicht mehr
so leistungsfähig wie in der
Vergangenheit
entscheiden dass Duell USA gegen China
Amerika droht sich innenpolitisch zu
zerlegen china hat wirtschaftliche
Schwierigkeiten es gibt aber ein
Unterschied zum Kalten Krieg China und
die USA sind wirtschaftlich
industriell
wissenschaftlich in vielfältigsterweise
miteinander verknüpft und haben insoweit
ein gemeinsames Interesse es nicht zu
weit zu treiben
nicht so weit treiben der Traum von
einer gemeinsamen Welt zumindest die
Bilder passend dazu
die westlichen G7 Staaten werden sich
vor allem dafür rüsten müssen ihr
Gesellschaftsmodell ihre liberalen
Demokratien zu verteidigen wegen Feinde
von außen und innen die teils ja auch
noch unheilige Allianzen eingehen noch
ist es so dass Menschen die aus
Diktaturen flüchten die politische
Freiheit erleben wollen sich ja eher
nach Europa oder Nordamerika aufmachen
die brix-staaten sind da offenkundig
weit weniger attraktiv
für Russen die vor Putin flüchten ist es
aber zumindest in Europa auch nicht
wirklich sicher der lange Arm Moskau
reicht weit Eva Schiller beschreibt wie
sehr sich Exil Russen in Deutschland
beobachtet fühlen wie verunsichert sie
sind und wie schwierig es für sie ist
überhaupt noch Kontakt zu Verwandten in
Russland zu halten
maria hat Angst um ihre Mutter im
Pflegeheim in Russland deshalb bittet
Sie uns kurz vor dem Interview ihr
Gesicht nicht zu zeigen auch den Namen
haben wir geändert die Russin lebt schon
seit vielen Jahren in Deutschland
arbeitet in der Finanzbranche bis zum
Ukraine Krieg pendelt sie zwischen
Moskau und Süddeutschland jetzt spürt
Maria der Kontakt in die Heimat er
schwindet
ich verliere meine russischen Verwandten
meine russischen Freunde ich verliere
mein letztes Stück Heimat plötzlich
sagen sie mir am Telefon dass ich ihr
Feind bin sie sagen guten Tag wir stehen
hinter unserem Präsidenten alles was du
und sagst glauben wir nicht
seit Ende 2022 kann jeder Russe der
Kontakt ins Ausland hat zum Agenten
erklärt verhaftet werden maria hat sich
öffentlich gegen den Krieg ausgesprochen
sie zeigt uns Listen mit den Namen derer
die sie daraufhin bedroht haben da
stehen Menschen aus Russland aber auch
Russen die in Deutschland leben
wir haben uns mit der Polizei getroffen
weil ich nicht die Einzige bin die
bedroht wird seit Kriegsbeginn fühle ich
mich in Deutschland nicht mehr sicher
meine Familie und meine Freunde wissen
wenn mir was passiert könnte der
russische Geheimdienst dahinterstecken
hat keine Angst mehr als
Wahlkampfmanager des inhaftierten
Oppositionellen nawalni weiß er was es
heißt seine Meinung zu äußern dreimal
saß er inhaft noch vor dem Krieg
flüchtet er nach Deutschland der Kontakt
nach Russland für ihn moralisches
Dilemma du möchtest ihn wie die
Information die Situation beeinflussen
aber du kannst nicht die Leute zum
Beispiel aufrufen auf die Straße zu
gehen ich könnte es mir nicht dann
verzeihen wenn wegen mir jemand der
verhaftet wird
es sind nur noch einige wenige die sich
trauen mit ihm zu sprechen wladislav ist
Journalistin Jekaterinenburg er muss
jedes Wort abwägen weil er im Visier der
Behörden ist
neulich haben mich den ganzen Tag zwei
Männer mit dem Auto verfolgt und manche
Dinge gewöhnst du dich einfach verlierst
Stück für Stück das Gefühl der Angst
aber viele meiner Bekannten gehen in die
innere Migration haben sich aus den
sozialen Medien abgemeldet und meiden
das Thema Ukraine
Maria zeigt uns wie der Kontakt zu ihren
Lieben in Russland versiegt am Anfang
waren da noch Diskussionen über den
Krieg mit der besten Freundin dann
flüchten sie sich in unverfängliche
Themen irgendwann brechen die Chats ab
Russen wie ich die verstehen was da
läuft die gegen den Krieg sind stecken
jetzt in einer tiefen Krise mein größter
Schmerz ist dass ich meine Mutter nicht
sehen kann dass ich sie nicht zu Grabe
tragen kann wenn sie stirbt in Marias
Auto wurde kürzlich ein Zelt geritzt das
Symbol von Unterstützern der russischen
Armee putinslanger Arm reicht bis nach
Deutschland da ist sie sich sicher
derweil der Krieg selbst mit
unverminderte Härte weitergeht wir haben
es ja vorhin schon gezeigt mit die
russische Armee heute einen Marktplatz
beschossen hat am hellichten Tag als die
Leute in ihrer Mittagspause einkaufen
gehen wie das ist wenn man sich täglich
in Lebensgefahr befindet täglich um
Angehörige Bank täglich sieht wie die
Heimat zerstört wird wie das ist das
versteht man am besten wenn man
einzelnen Menschen zuhört die das
Erleben und davon erzählen nächste Woche
erscheint ein Buch mit Briefen
ukrainischer Frauen Briefe an die
Außenwelt an uns der Titel wie ein
Lichtstrahl in der Finsternis davon
berichtet Christa
als es dunkel wurde sah ich ein glühen
am Himmel es waren Raketen
jeder neue Tag kann mein letzter sein
ich nehme das ohne Emotionen kühl und
nüchtern hin ich verspüre dabei keine
Angst Traurigkeit Panik oder andere
Gefühle es ist einfach eine Tatsache
die Weizenfelder wurden durch Raketen
Einschläge in Brand gesetzt und die
Ernte kann nicht vollständig eingebracht
werden
es ist höchste Zeit dass Frauen zu Wort
kommen was macht Krieg mit ihm was
machen Frauen im Krieg die
Deutsch-Französin aurelibro hat 38
Ukrainerinnen zwischen 10 und 72 Jahren
gebeten einen Brief zu schreiben über
das was wirklich los ist ihr Buch schaut
hinter Schlagzeilen und Front Berichte
bis morgen der Brief den ich schrieb ist
an keinen einzelnen Menschen adressiert
nicht mal an ein einzelnes Land sondern
an die Welt an die Menschheit ich finde
man sollte genau hinhören und vielleicht
einen Ausweg finden um diesen blutlichen
Krieg zu stoppen und den Frieden zu
leben
Frauen treffen überall im Krieg
Entscheidungen rund 60.000 kämpfen in
den Streitkräften sie sterben an
vorderster Front Tapferkeit hat kein
Geschlecht
die Idee war zu zeigen was die Ukraine
ist und nicht mehr rein ein Filter zu
haben ein Filter von Experten von von
Journalisten von Leute die schon so
gewisse Ideen haben über über die
Ukraine über den Krieg ich wollte
einfach diese Frau werden die sind
Frauen so die Möglichkeit geben sich
auszudrücken es war die Hölle es gab
kaum etwas zu Essen über dem Feuer wurde
Suppe für uns aus dem Wasser gekocht das
aus den Heizkörpern abgelassen wurde
diese sechs Monate waren die schlimmste
aber auch die erstaunlichste Zeit meines
Lebens denn parallel zu den Schrecken
des Krieges passiert gutes und starkes
noch nie war ich so glücklich meine
Freunde und Familie zu sehen
dieser Gedanke war mir wichtig dass ich
eine russische Oma und einen russischen
Opa habe zu denen ich keinen Kontakt
mehr habe es gibt viele Familien die
Verwandtschaft in Russland und in der
Ukraine haben manche unterstützen den
Krieg andere nicht knapp die Hälfte der
Frauen ist seit dem russischen Überfall
geflüchtet nach Boston oder Shanghai
viele nach Berlin Diener ist
Fernsehjournalistin seit Anfang des
Jahres kämpft sie an der Front wenn es
eine Gelegenheit gibt etwas zu
hinterlassen so habe ich die Chance
zumindest auf den Seiten dieses Buches
weiterzuleben
ein berührendes Buch ungeschminkt und
ehrlich mit einer guten Nachricht zum
Schluss alle Frauen lieben
und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal weiter
Gundula mit Wirtschaft
eines der Themen an den Finanzmärkten
ist die deutsche Wirtschaftsschwäche
mehrere aktuelle Umfragen und Studien
belegen die Stimmung zum Beispiel im
Außenhandel ist schlecht weil er real
hat zunächst eine Bestandsaufnahme wie
beurteilen Verbände und Institute die
aktuelle Lage nicht besonders gut jetzt
da sich weitere Wirtschaftsdaten
konkretisieren korrigieren Verbände und
Wirtschaftsforscher ihre Erwartungen
noch mal nach unten das Kieler Institut
für Weltwirtschaft rechnet nun für
dieses Jahr mit einem leichten Rückgang
der Wirtschaftsleistung vor allem der
Industrie bricht das Neugeschäft weg und
das schon seit Monaten und Grund ist
natürlich die weltweit schwache
Konjunktur vor allem in China
Deutschlands wichtigsten Handelspartner
Besserung ist dieses Jahr nicht in sich
das drückt auch auf die Stimmung an der
Börse wenn auch der DAX sich von seinem
Tiefstand wieder etwas erholt hat denn
zusätzlich beunruhigen auch die Ölpreise
aktuell ist Öl so teuer wie seit 10
Monaten nicht mehr die dem
ölriesensaudi-arabien und Russland
wollen an ihren Förderkürzungen bis
Jahresende festhalten keine guten
Vorzeichen für die Industrie die damit
als Wachstumsmotor noch eine Weile
ausfallen dürfte und wie sieht der Blick
in die Zukunft aus was lässt hoffen ja
es spricht schon einiges dafür dass
kommendes Jahr besser werden könnte vor
allem bei der Inflation rechnen die
Forscher mit deutlicher Verbesserung was
sich schon im September ankündigen
dürfte das sollte auch den Konsum
Stützen ja und ein weiterer Pluspunkt
der Arbeitsmarkt ist trotz Krise robust
geblieben viele rechnen damit dass das
auch so bleibt vielen Dank Valerie für
die Einschätzung
gleich zum Sport zunächst die
gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch ohne
Gewähr 3 6 8 13 20 47 Superzahl 2
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 5 5 7 die
deutschen Basketballer stehen zum ersten
Mal seit mehr als 20 Jahren wieder in
einem WM-Halbfinale am Freitag gegen die
Basketball Großmacht USA hart erkämpft
mit einem knappen Sieg gegen Außenseiter
Lettland kaum auszuhalten die Spannung
in der letzten Minute Deutschland in
Weiß hat eine komfortable Führung fast
schon verspielt nur noch zwei Punkte
Vorsprung und dann kann der heute arg
schwächelnde Kapitän Dennis Schröder
nicht für die Vorentscheidung sorgen nur
noch 7 Sekunden wenn David jetzt aus der
Distanzritt ist Deutschland geschlagen
das war knapp Deutschland im Glück die
lecken und tröstlich
es gibt seltenspieler wo ich wirklich
wirklich
dieser Spieler es ist aber auch der
Spiel des Franz Wagner zurückgekehrt
nach Knöchel Verletzung kompensierte
22-Jährige den schwachen Auftritt von
Schröder und wird zum man auch the match
deutschland hat mit Erreichen des
Halbfinales auch die
Olympia-Qualifikation geschafft
das war es von uns gleich geht es mit
dem auslandsjournal weiter unter anderem
mit einem Bericht über Wasser sparen in
Las Vegas
und
00:30 ist hier wieder Zeit für unser
heute journal Update mit Nazan göktem
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter diese Karte zeigt
uns die Temperaturabweichung für Juni
Juli und August also den Sommer den
metrologischen Sommer auf der
Nordhalbkugel und das war der wärmste
Sommer bisher nach den
Datenaufzeichnungen und das spielte sich
selbstverständlich auch in den Meeren
aus die zu warm sind z.B am Mittelmeer
hier dreht sich der tief Daniel und das
sorgte für diese exorbitanten
Regenmengen in Griechenland und das
nähert sich aus dieser Wärme ja und bis
morgen nachmittag setzen sich hier diese
Gewitter fort und da muss noch mal mit
sehr viel Regen gerechnet werden bei uns
weiterhin sehr ruhiges Wetter mit
teilweise sternenklamen Himmel ganz im
Süden bildet sich Nebel und hier bei 10
Grad ganz im Westen das bei 18 Grad
angesiedelt und
morgen dann viel Sonnenschein ganz im
Norden einige harmlose Wolken ansonsten
ein leichter bis mäßiger Ostwind
die Temperaturen dazu erreichen höchste
Werte von 31 Grad ganz im Westen das
sind wirklich die höchsten Werte des
morgigen Tages sonst aber auch 30 Grad
in der Nordhälfte und 25 Grad ganz im
Süden und die nächsten Tage weiter in
viel Sonnenschein teils Überschnitt
überdurchschnittlich warm bis 32 Grad
und das setzt sich bis Sonntag fort und
damit ein schöner Abend